hello my name is Celine Chevy I'm the
psyche general amnesty international
which is the largest human rights
movement of the world the question I'm
addressing as how are the decisions
you're making today and the policy is
your writing we remembered in a decade
essentially from now and I think that's
that question is asked by mail from
Hamburg Germany and I think that's a
very critical of any sort of relevant
question to ask in this forum because i
think that the decisions we make now in
relation to the economy and the way in
which we respond to the economic and
financial crisis really is going to have
some long-term advice and a pharmacy
international fundamentally you know
with 50 million more people slipping
into poverty as a result of the crisis
and more than 200 million people being
unemployed now this economic financial
crisis is starting to turn into a human
rights crisis and so there are two
dimensions is first of all I think what
we should be doing today because if you
don't it's going to have long-term
implications is to really bring to
account those who've caused this crisis
I must say when your form are actually
in this forum so no action is being
taken against the people who caused the
crisis is no great mystery about how it
happening and then the in terms of how
we are responding to the crisis i'm
talking about world leaders responding
to the crisis i'm afraid that what
they're doing is creating a double
whammy situation because the people who
created the crisis generally going
scot-free the consequence of the crisis
will be faced by those are marginalized
migrants women the poor generating and
what they're proposing now is to further
cut public expenditure cut social safety
nets and that's going to get get things
much worse instead we should be
investing from the majority of the
population and that's what's going to
reduce inequality and that's the way two
governments have a responsibility to
respect protecting and fulfill our human
rights obligations their signatories to
this commitment so the way to go for the
next ten years is really to look for a
human rights based society so thank you
very much